[Music]  identity access management as how you  can decide who does what with your  Google cloud resources you can get  incredibly specific when you create an  IM policy but essentially you have an  identity a role and a resource cloud IM  is designed with a clean universal  interface so you're able to manage  access across all Google cloud platform  resources consistently from App Engine  to GCE in this hands-on lab you'll learn  how to assign a role to a second user  and remove assigned roles associated  with Identity and Access Management or I  am during the lab you'll sign in with  two different usernames to experience  how granting and revoking access works  from both the viewer and owner role next  up on our quest is kubernetes engine  QuickStart  [Music]